alarms to go off this evening but if
there are any loans please follow the
direction of the officers on leaving the
building
uh item one on the agenda is apologies
have you got any questions
councillor james is delayed at work uh
he's on his way and apologizes that he
will be late
thank you
item two on the agenda is the council
manager on the second of august
i'll run through them page by page
there are any items that you wish to
speak on and please
then first page
page two
all right this is playing up across my
page okay three
four
five
six
seven
eight
nine
ten
and eleven
on page 12.
anyone
mr speaker
[Music]
if not someone had to move them as a
true record
yeah
secondly bye
[Music]
and abstentions
thank you
now item three is the action list
which is page 13
minute 2 or 2 has completed
and
item two one two
um
there was a question to sean carney
which is
or had a response
he was going to make contact with
councillor haynes
i'm not sure if he's done that already
but he's going to talk you through and
bring it up to speed with everything
that's going on there uh he said you're
already a member on the um
the estuary forum but as a northern time
council member there's no problem with
tourist history council being one
okay
thank you
for public contributions
[Music]
item five uh declarations of interest
for membership score now if there are
any
items that you need to declare on the
agenda please describe them when we get
a gender item
item six is agreement of uh agenda items
part one and two
point of order
question four
um
[Music]
b
please
i think this is in reference to what's
coming up later in positivity
while she's looking for that another
question for the chairman which is
relevant
i'd like you to ask all members not
nurse
whether they actually went before that
are you in the whistle-blowing policy
i have a hard copy that i can share with
them that they haven't really digested
it
if you could read that out you know
more elegantly
just give stacey a minute to gather her
thoughts before we do that
11-5b
ensuring lawfulness and fairness of
decision making the head of legal and
governance and monitoring officer will
after consulting with the chief
executive and the finance manager and
section 151 officer when necessary
report to the full council if he or she
considers that any proposal decision or
admission would give rise to
unlawfulness or if any decision or
omission is given rise to mal
administration
such a report will have the effect of
stopping the proposal or decision being
implemented until the report has been
considered thank you for that exactly
okay in my hand now
that i have to use and coach the
christine was actually quite shocked an
f-o-i-s-a-r
to get what i was actually allowed to
have
this is the contrived nonsense by
country mcgovern against most of the
complaints against me but let's stick to
this one
fold please
surely this is this should be discussed
in part two later
well i don't know whether i am trying to
complain so what i'm suggesting now you
might want to leave your way
from me i'm
i suggest
the itunes in part two is actually
kicked out it goes to internal overview
and scrutiny
could i have a proposal
for part two please and the second uh
stop the transmission tommy